yeah um
this here we go so
hi who are you yo what up
shanks is in the building shanks yeah
what up
okay okay now i get it so get it
you would have been a prisoner boy
griffin no i have i have not been in
prison
oh you you hit you heading no because if
you would
you'd be a tasty treat in there
wait uh is it gonna get a little debbie
big debbie's in town
are you gonna eat me or is that yeah
uh so uh
so shanks my question is now that you're
out of prison
why are you still wearing the outfit
you're on freshly out i haven't had time
you know to get new clothes so i mean we
about the same size so if you want to
hook it up
i might be able to change i appreciate
you saying that we're the same size this
ain't sagging
saying statue i see you looking you
looking trim man griffin you looking
trend huh
okay so when you say freshly out like is
it legally out
or i mean i wouldn't get into that
exactly at the moment like i'd rather
not be talking about that but i do
appreciate
your letters to me that you were riding
to keep me going and keeping me going
getting it going you know what i'm
saying i wrote i wrote you letters yeah
yeah okay forget dms
you get wait you get handwritten
notebooks not letters that's what
shane's just getting
wait can i ask you yeah yeah again well
what i'm an open book
okay spread my covers baby where is
jeremiah what you talking about doc
didn't you get letters from him too yo
you said
break out of prison i did not wait what
yeah you said break out of prison you
said come on my body
okay and then and then you said
we moving in together what yeah you said
all that in that letter listen with my
viewership i think i would try a stunt
like this
[Laughter]
yo we trying to get these numbers up dog
yo yeah we
my next guest you will shank live on the
podcast
um but okay uh shanks uh do you even do
you know jeremiah watkins you know who
i'm talking about not really but i mean
you know i could maybe look him up on
the google or whatever
do you know about the group how long
have you been in prison do you know
about google have you been here
we got ibm the last time i went in there
you know what i'm saying
so we had internets and stuff like that
and webs and stuff like that
for like a hot minute but like i'm not
too familiar the last uh social media
that i was on was
anger zanga yeah
you know this anger dog used to put
journal entries online
tell your secrets and then if you like
that person you show me your secrets
i don't know you know i put myself
through this
every time you know what i mean last
time
feminist stacy was here okay you know do
you even do you know feminism yeah she a
bad [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i don't think she would like you i mean
i bet
she would hate my guts actually
and so now we have uh shanks
no when we hitting that that theme song
don what
when we hit that these on dawg well i
mean i actually i
i i don't know i mean the podcast was
supposed to start differently it usually
starts differently
what do you mean it's all different i
mean i'm a little different
yeah that's uh and then i have a little
wipe there because you know you know
about
corona right yeah corona i was locked up
with a girl named corona for like
90 days until they found out that she
was actually a man
and um then um
we started you know seeing each other on
the
oh man this and this i gotta you know
how do you know about the new iphone
so the new iphone yeah i smuggled a new
iphone inside my butt
crack the last time i went into jail
okay okay yeah
okay ladies and gentlemen welcome to
your favorite podcast
[Music]
yeah yo yo we whippin but griffin
that's jordan i'm pippin you better not
be slipping you gotta be listening
he just got engaged his girlfriend
straight drifting you know who it is
shanks in the building okay
shanks is in the building
feeling good man
[Music]
all right okay please don't
[Music]
always say this down i don't want to
scare the viewers or anything
yo who makes your bees dog because i
need a new producer i've been through
like six producers
i'll be out here trying to rap in these
streets it ain't happening yet though
okay so you you also rap yeah you know
you just saw a little bit of that that
flame stick
okay listen i don't know where jeremiah
is
oh you want me to go get him you go
i need to go get him like yesterday yeah
does everyone need a habit
yes okay well you know i guess i could
be riding a new man i guess i guess i'll
see you soon eric griffin
but yes thank you shanks everybody
fresh out of prison
uh why do i put myself through this you
know what i mean
it's like my nightmare podcast would be
rick glassman jeremiah watkins
and like steve lee if those three were
on the podcast at the same time
nightmare
absolute and utter nightmare but it is
what it is ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to riffin with griffin
we are you know going strong once again
i got a
guest this week special guest because he
has a his
very own hour special coming out and i
said to him you need to come on and
promote that and talk about that
and i haven't seen him he's got some
good personal news going on a
very talented guy so miss you also catch
me um
on twitch every single day i do error
griffin gaming on twitch and youtube and
make sure you also
if you want to um i do private warzone
matches because they have that option
now on saturday mornings at 10 a.m if
you go to air graphic gaming you join me
and
you know what the fans and friends and
we are doing that playing warzone
against each other
so make sure you check that out but once
again thank you for watching subscribing
and sharing and all that kind of stuff
and we're just trying to
grow the podcast during these crazy
times because there is a lot of
craziness
going on right now you know i've been
talking about covert a lot
talk about covert a lot and now it's
like really coming to a head
right so be safe out there and wear your
masks so ladies and gentlemen welcome to
the podcast
here he is mr jeremiah watkins
my friend sorry i'm late man
i know that you get really mad when
people say that they're parking and then
they're not actually outside your place
yet
i told eric like 15 minutes ago that i
was parking
and he kept saying where are you at
and uh i apologize i actually i hadn't
left my place yet
when i was texting you you know what i
hate when people do that yeah
you know i hate it's like just tell me
where you are bro i had no joke
i had a friend who we were waiting my
wife and i were waiting on this guy
at lunch we're gonna meet him yeah it
was his idea for lunch first of all so
that makes it more annoying
oh it was their idea and then they're
late to the whole thing yeah yeah yeah
yeah
so then we're like where are you at dude
and he goes uh
oh uh i'm parking
okay great yeah 45 minutes go by
and this dude rolls up like nothing was
wrong he's like hey guys
traffic it was crazy it was like from
the meter to here traffic was crazy
he said you're parking outside yeah see
here's the thing is like people think
that they're
gonna disappoint you by being i'm gonna
be no no no
what's more disappointing is you giving
me some expectations that you're gonna
walk in the [ __ ] in five minutes
right and it's 45 minutes later i can't
stand that i i i used to can't
this is like cause i'm old school you
know i'm older than you so like
but back in the day you had to like when
you let's say i'm coming to pick you up
you know i actually had to drive to your
place and i either had to honk the horn
yo jeremiah i'm here right or i had to
get out knock on the door yep so
back in those days it's like if i tell
you i'm picking you up at eight
be ready at eight hello be outside
be right back 7 59. just to be looking
for me
be ready at eight i'm gonna keep driving
i'm gonna pop my door open
you jump in i'm leaving her at like two
and you dude so like those were the days
where like you actually had to be a
little bit more considerate because
how annoying is it that i got a park
right
knock on your door like where are you
man i'm outside waiting yeah people
still did that kind of stuff there's not
that like
give me three more minutes saying it's
like no i don't have no way to
communicate once they're gone from their
from their house i don't know how it was
when you were dating your girl you know
now that she's your wife now but like
you know because that used to be the
thing with dating like certain women you
you know you're going to pick them up
and i felt like
they don't start getting ready until you
go i'm here
[Laughter]
yeah i think they waited at the window
naked like where is he because i need to
get in the shower
yeah you know so you see okay i'm coming
down
i'm actually my wife gets on me because
i am sometimes that person you're that
guy
i will well she times have changed i'm
like
it's the new me i will put off
getting ready until the last minute and
then i'll be
usually within five or ten of like
uh but she's usually waiting for me out
the door like are you are you ready yet
and i i've just been
that's the artist in you though yeah
unless there's unless it's like a call
sheet that's the only time we're on time
right or the only time that we sign our
name
properly is when we're getting paid yeah
we need to tell like we need to tell our
you know
tell our significant others like just
have a call sheet just send me a call
sheet in the mail
you know and i'll be like oh i got to
get 16. yeah yeah i gotta get them
i gotta be here what's my call time and
then have somebody call me i'm the pa
yeah when are we having sex
okay yeah i'll be there i'll be there
yeah i know so
but anyways jeremiah's here thanks for
coming on man
uh dude i miss you man it's been like i
know there's only like a handful of
friends that i've gotten to see
like in person and we shot that music
video that's already been like months
now i know right
but it's crazy like that was the first
time i've seen you since march yeah i
don't know what
i don't know how it was for you but i
was like on the road in march i was i
was just crazy i was in tennessee
at chattanooga i have been uh the last
stop i think i made was in san antonio
texas
and while i was on stage after i got off
stage they're like
somebody just broke out with code at the
mall like it felt like a zombie outbreak
movie somebody's like somebody has it at
the mall i'm like
that mall like right over there yeah
dude yeah it was weird
it's crazy how flimsy like no we were
way more scared at first
yeah that's like like super scary
absolutely you know what i mean it's so
unknown but
you're actually good you don't have to
have it it's actually picking up good oh
it's better out here yeah yeah it's
picking up real good cool
yeah uh yeah i'm actually too loud i can
hear it
a little bit yeah yeah yeah but it's
cool the um yeah it was like
the first because like but that actually
helped my relationship rachel and i got
really close because of like that first
like like two months of
uh just being like 24 hours a day her
and i
we worked through all our [ __ ]
quarantine was a true test man it really
was you
you like you i'm getting closer you're
getting married congrats by the way i
haven't got to see you in person since
you know what i mean so now i'm like so
it's like that's that's the crazy
part but like it was so it cut to now
here we are
and now it's like very anecdotal like
how people feel about
covet it's well it's probably the
problem is it's still serious but
everybody's just tired they've just
grown fatigued from the idea of it so
it's like
it's like well i also think that you
know i also think i talk i've talked
about it a lot i get all these people
hit me up i get scientists hit me up i
get people mad
you know but now where we're at right
now
which is crazy is because the thing that
they were worried about in the beginning
that actually didn't happen is happening
now
because we went into lockdown not
because necessarily that covet was
dangerous
it was unknown what was about it you
know it was they were they didn't know
but more it was more about we can't have
the hospital system getting overrun
because everybody's going in
and that didn't happen because they shut
down they locked down you know but we
were so
keen to do it then because we were like
all right i'm being safe but then when
[ __ ] start losing money and the
lies are ruined then they're like hey
wait a minute what's going on here cause
i don't know anybody that's got it and
that's the problem with it too
it's like most people don't know one
person you know they're close to that
they're close to
their immediate circle that's say well
that has died of it
you know right we know a lot of people i
mean santino did that's what i'm saying
we know like
we know people yeah we know people have
gotten into work see this is the and i
think that that is
the the problem with how how people deal
with it is
we know a hundred times more people that
have gotten it
and gotten over it and they're fine
because this is our age group though
yeah
but but i know but uh but i think that
that's what makes it hard for people to
be like why are we locked down
you know why am i not going to work why
am i can't go outside why can't you know
so i can understand the dilemma
you know and i've been all i've just
been asking the question like can you go
out like justify it for me like you know
where
have the scientists out there being like
listen i know this is hard financially
and everything's bad right now
for you but it's better for it to be bad
for you financially than for
this covey to you know explain it to me
because with the numbers you just go
what's going on
but now the numbers are starting to like
big people go whoa wait a minute what's
going on so it's happening right in
front of our eyes you know
so anyways that's not we don't want to
go onto all that but you know so cut to
you right now you know
i'm closer with my girl you're does
everybody know about your
situation yeah yeah yeah yeah my wife is
pregnant she's uh oh i thought it was
about your herpes
didn't know that we were talking about
that on the podcast yeah
jeremiah is having a baby and i'm so
glad it's so great because like when you
first
i remember i've been talking about this
with you forever i know
whatever i'm like i remember going to
your
place and like and she loved me because
i was like get her pregnant dude and she
was like yeah
get me like that and you were just like
no oh my god what are you doing man
you were so apprehensive yeah yeah you
still scared are you worried what is it
now how are you feeling i feel way
better about it now like i'm
i'm i've grown into the more excited
phase of that it's happening you know
what i mean
uh stages of grief you've gone through
them absolutely
dude if i wasn't a little bit scared i'd
be insane yeah yeah
like it's a huge life change so
but i mean it's one of those things
where i think it's gonna be an
enhancement
and the way that i work with everything
i think is gonna
to push me and drive me to work harder
and all that stuff
so the things that you were worried
about before though being at like are
you
i'm too young or i'm not ready i don't
have enough money i don't have like all
the things that you were worried about
before like where are those things for
you now
is it like you do you think about them
now like ah what was i worried about
that for or are you just more in a
different gear
what's in your i'm in a different gear
so i'm a very logical guy
so like the money stuff and and like
certain things with with life stuff
that's still like there but i've
relocated it to a more healthier place
if that makes sense
yeah dude it makes perfect sense because
i'm actually dealing with that in my own
way because
rachel hates this place okay sure yeah
you know what i mean which my wife hated
my old place i was at my old place for
like over five years and it was a
bachelor place i had two roommates
and she like i'm grateful that she was
willing to even stay there
at my place and stuff like that because
it was a total bro house
like it wasn't that clean like you know
coming out the bathroom and they were
like what's up girl snapper
good game was like what the game
showered why are you touching my ass
yeah it was weird so it was like uh that
was one of those things where she kind
of nudged me along like we should get a
place together and i was like
same thing i was like i was terrified
man i was like i don't know about
what i'm ready to like and she's like
the final thing where she goes i guess
i'll move in with my sister then and
that just was like
oh you're moving in with your little
sister you know what
they're master manipulators i mean it
was it
it did it for me they know how to do it
i was like you're
gonna move in with your little sister
that was just that was just that was
just a subtle ultimatum
it really was you know what i mean you
just go okay we need that push you know
we need to
think we do we need to push it's fine
and dude since
every nudge so far that she's given me
as far as like relationship in life
it has been the best thing yes it really
has been so she's been
nudging me along with the this baby
thing for as you know years
i know it's been a long time so i think
it's going to be
an amazing thing that uh i'll be very
grateful for that we didn't wait any
longer than we did
yeah it was great so jeremiah called you
call me you know i'm talking like i'm
talking to them i'm talking to you so
they uh
you it was great when you called because
you said something like hey i got some
important news
that was like the wording you used and
as soon as i saw that i already knew
right like i literally knew i was like
hey man i can't talk right now but
congratulations on
having a baby yeah yeah right now you're
like yeah yeah
i was like how did i ever know and i
showed my like next week and she started
laughing she's like how did
how do you know because that would be
the only important news yeah
you know that you would did you like i
would call you we're close
you know what i mean we're close you
know what i mean and you know we're
friends you know but it's like we have
different
like peer groups and that kind of you
know what i mean so like
for you to be calling me about something
important i i i what what the [ __ ] would
that be yeah
if i booked something you'd be like why
is he calling me about booking something
this is the most hollywood phone call
ever why would jeremiah do that to me
i thought we were better friends with
that you know and even if it was
something like super personal i was like
what super personal thing would he call
me about yeah
and i just i just knew that that's what
it was you know eric it's your baby
oh dude that's a man i just remind you
of this show i'm watching leap of faith
what's that with the chick from uh who
was the [ __ ] one
on uh sex in the city uh kim cantrell
oh she stars in this show on fox where
she's like this like
preacher lady like oprah but like
christian and it's the most convoluted
show the [ __ ] that's going on the show
but anyway something like that happened
on the show i don't know why i brought
that up but you don't even but anyways
it's just a great show i might talk
about it on a podcast another time
because it's just so like you got me
interested yeah it's just
yeah yeah she's like the head of this
anyway i don't even wanna
that's for a different episode a
different episode cause like her husband
got
killed but he survived that's faith in
with griffin
yeah i do too many of that stuff i love
it something that is branded i love it
it has your name in it it's memorable
what's happening with griffin um yeah
man so
you know so here you are you about to
have a baby like for me like the move
the like moving was hard because
she wanted to we just moved yeah i said
i said listen
i'm willing to move right then covet hit
and my job changed yeah you know what i
mean like i was like
i'm not on a show i don't i don't got
like my
my podcast isn't bad friends i don't get
i don't i don't get an unjustified
number of viewers
whoa
shots fire barrier
you know what i mean so i was like i i i
can't just like
do the expense but then i switched into
gaming you know
and like yeah the gaming stuff really
started to take off like i'm hosting
you're getting good now but you've
always been good but like i've been
seeing some of your videos even post
lately
i'm like just because i play every day
yeah and so now i'm hosting a new show
like even on twitch we're doing like
four episodes of this show on twitch i
do my own shameless plug it's called
potluck
i'm hosting it with lisa milambri
and it's going to be on the twitch
channel on the crown channel wednesdays
at 9 00 8 p.m i think it is 8 p.m on the
crown channel
anyways so it's like a variety show
great they were just hosting from home
but i've gotten so many opportunities
from
gaming so then like financially i was
like all right well i'm doing all right
and then she's like complaining like i
can't stand the water pressure
i can't like it's like it's like the
things that they
they gripe about oh yeah you had uh you
have to hear them
you know when she put the tone it won't
flush properly
it's always some kind of thing i hate
your refrigerator so i was like all
right
i don't have a bed you know the normal
stuff
you make me sleep outside yeah
that's how she makes it right right so
then i found a spot and it's just more
expensive and then like i had this whole
thing about
buying versus renting like what do you
think about that cause like in la
you know in la it's like i you know it's
like i'm not broke
you know i got money in the bank did i
save and i invest and all this kind of
stuff and i thought okay i want to buy a
plate but i want to buy a place that i
like i don't want to just buy a place to
buy just to buy a place yeah people like
invest your money in a condo and reseda
like no i don't want to live
nothing you also don't by the way no
offense to anybody that lives in recede
i just don't want to live in a valley
shout out shout out to cobra kai man
yeah
exactly i don't want to i don't want to
live in in the hot ass valley i like
living on the west side
but that costs money and i'm like i'm
not ready
are you guys still gonna be in this area
yeah we're about a couple miles away
okay like you know you know so i was
like and it's a new
nice new building i was like oh this is
great you know i yeah
you know so i i pulled the trigger and
now we're moving
but the way so my wife and i just moved
in it is a little bit more of an
expensive place
but we are home so much more than we
used to be
right so that's the kind of the way that
we're looking at it is like i have a
little office
space now yeah that like i didn't have
before i was doing all my work
or in our living room or that you didn't
know you needed as she needed
yeah well she is a teacher and she's
been doing
like eight hours a day at zooms so like
we need
separation we need a little bit of space
so she can have her time and then also
just so she's not hearing me
recording voice over random stuff in the
other room
like i would have to tell her when i had
a voiceover audition come up
can you be quiet like 20 to 30 minutes
that's a lot to ask a person to not when
they're home when they're home yeah
that's a lot so
rachel comes and she like closes my door
with an attitude you know
yeah cause i'm in here like you know get
your loadout on me
on me you know what i mean like how am i
playing call of duty she's like i wish
you'd get his load out on me
i mean seriously i've been here the
whole time like what's going on it's
funny that she actually had a response
like that because she was like what are
you talking about in there
talking about your load again so she
just comes and she closes the door with
a little bit of an attitude right it's
not a slam
but that last two inches yeah it's like
shut the [ __ ] up
you know what i mean so now we have a
place it's like it's like three stories
and it's like
you know i have it was two-bedroom you
know we had the anyways it's better
place
so and i'm sure you'll have more room
for your twitch stuff too
exactly yeah i'm sick of this little
space i saw chappelle on rogan
right when daniel rawlings was on there
shout out to donnell love him happy
birthday to him too who just had his
birthday
um but chappelle said something very
profound
about you know he said what's going on
at covet is like
what what we've been forced to do is
live with our choices
you know and he was talking about like
where like where you live
you know what you do for fun the things
you have in your place yeah like so
covet made us be here at home and we
have to like okay do you like where you
live
yeah do you like this person you're with
do you like you know so
you start second-guessing things you
start going ugh dude i don't like this
or i don't like that
and so i'm at that point where i was
like you know what you know i've worked
hard
spent you know if yeah so what's because
i was like you were logical were
practical
for me to be like let's stay here until
we buy a you know
but if dude that's how i was like with
the other place i was just like
we could stay here another five ten
years and then you know what my hand is
yeah that's the first thing need a deal
right now
it's la oh my god yeah dude i
i went to i was looking at places dude
there's
do you ever look at some of these
newfangled buildings around la right now
you look at the thing the listing
there's one over here dude
9 000. it's a month it's insane
what yeah durant yeah
huh what who
are you yeah also do you think i'm iron
man
that i have disposable income does this
no i have some giant inheritance
who are they gonna like imagine the
douchebags that are gonna fill that
place up
like who's who's gonna live there i bet
they'll turn some of those into
influencer spaces
have you heard of these influencer
spaces i get it i mean
i mean i guess there are a lot of more
rich people than we realize that
just want to have like a spot you know
you know it's like
just want to feel connected like oh i
have a place in l.a right right right
49. somebody's but by the way
that's the kind of person that i don't
mind having a 9 000
rent place but if like some of these
people you see them you go like
to me it feels like
if you're paying 9 000 a month which is
basically
over a hundred grand a year
for a place just to rent just to rent
that's not all your expenses and
everything you know
well what do you do like what are you
doing like are you living
beyond your means well yeah are you like
what's your job
because like my thing is like if you're
rich why the [ __ ] you living in a
it doesn't seem like that's a rich
person move it just it see
it seems like like rich people know how
to invest their money you know what i
mean so
they're not renting a nine thousand
dollar place that's what i'm saying
so who's living there what kind of
person daddy
daddy yeah daddy i want to live in l.a
yeah okay so that's why i found this
great bargain
it's only nine thousand and that's nine
thousand dollars
or some like shake son who like goes to
ucla
right yeah but i want my son to have a
good education
and i want him to live in a proper means
i want to live in a compound so who so
who that's what i'm saying so the people
that live there they're not
they can't be the the kind of people
they're not they're not real people
they're not they can't be real
they don't have personality they don't
have personality there's no way they
they haven't done anything they haven't
had struggles they have no struggles
they have no character who are they what
kind of like that's the sketch
is like about a building full of people
where their rent is 9000 a month and
they don't even know how money works
yeah i'll take it what
uh really like like the person wrote the
number this slides it
towards them just tears it up whatever
it is
and fill it with things oh no
what's up guys thank you for watching
we're from with griffin and guess what i
have a
great new sponsor for the show this is
brought to you by
better help better h-e-l-p
help now what do i always say when i'm
doing my real-world advice from a
grown-ass man
i always have to stop and pause and let
everybody know that if you
really are struggling out there if you
have depression you have anxiety
and you really need some help you feel
lost i always tell you
get therapy go out and get some
professional help and now i have a
sponsor of the show
that i can send you to and this is
better help
we all have stuff that interferes with
our happiness we all have things that
stop us from achieving our goals or
or getting past certain things in our
lives like for me it was boundary issues
you know i was letting people take
advantage of me
you know and i had to go to therapy to
help me work through that that saying
no is okay and you know sometimes
therapy has a stigma and i'm just here
to let you know right now
they're not going to solve your problems
they're going to help you work through
them they're going to help you
understand them
with a professional and that's what
better help does
they connect you in a safe private
online environment
which is great you don't have to be
sitting in some crazy waiting room or
feel embarrassed that oh what is that
person here for
they looking at you like oh that person
crazy you don't have to have those kinds
of feelings at all you can start
communicating right now within 24 hours
it's easy setup it's not self-help it's
professional counseling and that's what
this is right now professional
counseling that's what better help
offers you can send a message to a
counselor at any time
and you'll get timely thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions all without
having to say like i say sit in some
really weird
waiting room the service is available to
clients
all over the world there's a broad range
of expertise available which
may not be locally available in many
areas because we all deal with
a lot of these issues like i say when i
do real-world advice from a grown-ass
man
i get people that have depression stress
anxiety
you're having trouble in your
relationships if you're having trouble
sleeping if you have
trauma from anger if you have if you
have
lgbt matters uh grief if you have
self-esteem issues
better help is here to help you
anything you share is confidential and
it's convenient it's
it's professional and most importantly
it's
affordable you can check out
testimonials on their website
right now go to betterhelp.com that's
h-e-l-p
slash griffin all right
i want you to start living a happier
life today as a listener you'll get
10 off your first month by visiting our
sponsor at
betterhelp.com that's h e
l p slash griffin guys
join over one million people who have
taken charge of their mental health
again that's better help h-e-l-p
dot com slash griffin let's get
happy and healthy out there let's get
back to the show
so i again you and me both were just
like i just feel like i'm just way more
practical about
but then like when you get someone in
your life you realize your practical
logical thinking
has nothing to do with like you weighed
versus like happiness yeah
her being happy is so much more
important than me saving money do you
yeah i mean yeah do you and rachel
uh plan on having kids yes i'm sure
you know she talks about it so okay so
what's happening
yeah so you know but when she when we
got because we had broken up
and then when we got back together she
made it very clear you know
i want a family you know i you know that
was like a big part of
going back into it like this is the
agreement going and for me i knew that
that's what i said i know i'm ready
let's do it you know and then covet hit
to test it which was
what i said which was great no bigger
test yeah it's almost like you know it's
like that's that's
just test this relationship do you know
anyone who was like
it didn't work it did you know you don't
want to say their name you have to say
their names
yeah you know a couple people was like
yeah he was like
he just he just says his you know wife
or her husband's name and they're just
like
yeah yeah that happened to some people i
know yeah man yeah i know some people
too that it just like it just didn't
work out
well you're spending way more time with
them so you like all the things that
like
pissed you off or whatever before like
it's heightened like crazy aunt but did
you
did you find yourself in this time
end up cutting anybody out like
friend-wise where you're like
where you're like oh yeah oh i i think
i'm done with that person oh
bro i unfollowed people on instagram i
just i realized like oh we don't talk
we're not friends
right you know especially like even like
like comics and stuff i realized i was
like oh we're just hallway buddies
right i just know you in the hallway at
the comments between your story
you're sort of nice to me or but you're
not we're not really friends yeah you
don't care if i live or die
right you know what i mean and i just
thought and then even some people that i
thought
we were way closer i realized oh i'm not
really close to that person because
when it all hits the fan you just gonna
vanish on me you know yeah there's a lot
of vanishers out there oh there's a lot
of banishing acts right now dude you
know and
there's a lot of things that have gone
on to kami's story you know with chris
dalia and joe rogan leaving and
and then like people leaving the comedy
store people leaving la and
and all these things that are going on
dude brian cowan and all everything
that's happened
you know it's challenged everybody's
notion of like who their friends are and
what loyalty means tony hinchcliffe and
brian redman uh are moving to austin
yeah so and the you know those guys are
super close friends of mine who are like
in my inner circle and stuff like that
and yeah we just
found out real recently about that yeah
it's like
wow you know i was i was
yippy happening with rogan by text and
he was like you should move to austin
you know like [ __ ] ain't moving to
austin
i get why you know he wants to build
wait wait
a scene there jeremiah i get it listen
when you have a hundred million dollars
in a bank
you live on planet earth okay
you know what i'm saying like he he's
the kind of guy now that
he got a summer home and whatever right
he got a ranch and so and so
he got you know he got acres in montana
he that kind of guy now
he's in an elite class of people that
kind of money that like he's not
from l.a from he's on earth wherever he
wants to live right
but but tony
they're doing it but when you think
about it is why be in la
like if you're a podcaster you know if
you're
uh if you're if you've moved into that
sort of media or if you're not
that's the thing if you're not in front
of the camera i'm saying exactly
then why would you yeah you don't need
to be here well because stand up you're
on the road anyway
exactly but for me for la
i i think that la is going to come back
like it's going to come back eventually
like to where it was this might take a
little bit longer than we'd like
but like i audition and i act and stuff
so
i i want to be here i don't think it's
gonna completely gravitate overnight
it's still hollywood like it's it would
take a lot for it to
moved completely to atlanta or you know
what i mean to different places you know
what though man
i don't know i i actually i don't know
if i agree
one thing that they can't one thing that
they can't take back that's happening
now and i'll give you an example of
something is um
therapy for instance so before my
my particular therapist she like
partially retired
but she said but i'm still doing web
therapy i'll do webster
came out of retirement when the
quarantine happened no no no she was
already deciding to do web there yeah
you know she said i'm gonna do i'm not
gonna
i'm not gonna go to the office anymore
insurance wouldn't cover it
right but quarantine hit and then they
made it
okay yeah but the thing about it is
you can't go backwards right so like
there's a lot of things we're doing now
by zoom by web that no i don't need to
go
i don't need to go to such and such you
know even if you think about some of
these writers rooms and stuff like
do they actually do they always need to
be in the same room
yeah what are these zoom meetings and
stuff are working out i did an acting
class through
zoom that's what i'm saying dude acting
i've done commercial auditions through
zoom
that stupid it's weird but
i think we're gonna get used to some of
the so i think some of the things that
are incorporated
and so then you also think about like
even before this happened
you know productions were moving to
boston a lot of productions moving to
boston for the tax breaks
atlanta's got a whole hollywood scene
yeah you know vancouver all these
different places
so i don't know if this is los angeles
is is going to be this mecca of
hollywood anymore
in the way it was i think this is gonna
chip away and i don't know if it's gonna
go back
that's my thoughts what do you think i
think i'll bounce back because
there's too many people who love
la to let that happen i think it will go
through a period where it's rough
for like movies being made and stuff but
i think that the talent who
feel like la is their city of dreams i
think there's too much nostalgia and
stuff
with that but maybe the next 20 years
that's gonna
keep shifting and stuff like that but i
think that people will try to get it to
go back to that
just on the fact alone that they're like
this is where i made it or i'm trying to
make it i'm too resistant to
believe that it's not the city of angels
in the city of dreams anymore
yeah but every audition that i've gone
on in the past even before covet
um very few of the things shoot in la
yeah so yes i mean you know mr freaking
netflix over here
yeah every time i turn on netflix eric
griffin walking through
but even when you say that like you know
the murder mystery uh
or the adam sandler movie i was in i'm
the first thing you hear and see but
anyway um
if you had hair you would have flipped
it there
anyway but um that we shot that in
vancouver in montreal you know uh
the sleepover netflix slot shot that in
boston
you know so i mean there are certain
movies i know it's hot you get to go
ahead
i'm wearing your old uh merch i was
about to say you did that on purpose
wow how dare you hello
[Laughter]
i'm so tired of that joke by the way
like that's this is one of the jokes i
get on the internet like
at nauseum it's like you know you look
like the thing i said i get it
you know tell me something original i
heard this already
i want to sell those for halloween um
so that would be a great like make your
own
like like your own pack your eric
griffin starter pack
yeah that'd be great you have a singer
mike this is a singing mic on the side
and then the
griffin with griffin griffin in with
griffin i don't know
so i don't know man i just feel like a
lot of [ __ ] is going is out of town
everything is like you know this half of
the stuff you see
is not even shooting in la anyway i mean
the th
la was the starting point is what i'm
saying so like the starting point of
like
the ages are here auditions are here
right okay
we're learning now you don't have to be
here to do that that's what i'm saying
so if you don't have to be here to do
that
what what do you what's the point of
being here so i get why some people are
leaving
i get right and it's so expensive i'm
from l.a i was born and raised so i love
la i'm gonna be here
you know but there's part of me that
thinks like hey you know seattle's nice
uh
sure pacific north there's a lot of
beautiful places in the specific
northwest there's like you know it's
like
i was looking at even i was looking at
houses in austin in dallas
my god well you can get it oh yeah over
what you can get there yeah i mean
that's what
that's what brian just did i mean it's
like what you know
but then you go but i do you think that
part of it is like when when someone
decides i'm leaving la and they go move
something else do you think there's a
part of them that thinks that they're
giving up i don't
think oh i think that that's part of the
fear of people
not leaving the people who who are
are staying i think that that's
definitely like a feeling of like
no i gotta ride this through you know
what i mean the people who i think
people that are moving are confident
like they have the means necessary like
they can move back
it's the people like who are on that
bubble of like
dude of resetting your life like this
that would be make or break to
to get up and move everything and not
feel comfortable
you know what i mean yes the people that
have enough means to be like i'll be
good and
it like pops back open i can always move
back i'll swing back to l.a
like all right that's you know that's
different yeah
i i guess i mean because you got to
think there's a lot of people who are
like
you know of our community of people that
we know they're like oh they're trying
to
get in at the comedy store or they're
like there's like these things that are
doing and then you take all those things
away
and you gotta wonder like what do people
think they are now like
who are they i think that's why there's
a lot of people who've had identity
crises during this weird time right yeah
yeah i mean there's multiple comedians
who i know who
took their own life because they weren't
in a happy state because
you take that away and if you were only
doing comedy comedy comedy
you stopped developing what you needed
to as a person
like with interpersonal relationships
which helps your comedy
yeah you grow from that and like
personal experience and just life
experience if you're only doing stand-up
like
you're not really just living life i was
uh
it was hard for me at first it really
was that first like
few weeks so you so on top of now rachel
was
thrusted on me in terms of like because
it was like what am i gonna tell her no
you know she didn't want to be where she
did she asked or like what how did that
come about oh it wasn't even it was like
why
i have to move in with you because i
can't be with my family because i work
and
covid and my dad you know it was all
this stuff and i was like
i was like okay you know what i mean
well i'm gonna say no yeah you know what
i mean
it's like so it wasn't even like can we
talk about it no it was just like you
know
when you're in a relationship with
somebody sometimes it's just like this
is happening yeah
[ __ ] hits the fan yeah who are you there
you know what i mean like who am i in
this relationship if i'm gonna be like
well hold on a second no so anyways you
know so it was like so
so on top of like having that thrusted
on my life right
comedy gets taken away from me so all
the things that i do to deal with it
deal with my life i just would go on
stage and just release
oh dude i didn't realize until staying
away how much i was screaming on stage
i was like i would have certain sets
like hey you know what i mean just like
that's how i'd get some of my energy out
and that that was a great release for me
and that's taken away he's like
oh i gotta find some different outlets
you gotta find different outlets you can
try
i luckily have like a yeah like i beat
my wife now okay you know
we go a few rounds you know it's fun she
wins mostly
[Laughter]
ronda rousey you know dude not
attractive right
i would not want to and women are that
strong like
like physically i'm like i'm out like
i'm like that's just not attractive to
me listen i like you know what i like to
at least
think that like if i wanted to i could
hold them down
you know what i mean that's not even for
me my thing is like i like girly girls
i like dainty girl they got like girls
who don't like spiders and who are like
oh my god can you carry that you know i
like that i like drama
okay baby yeah i like exactly i got you
like i like drama queens i like that
kind of thing
i don't like athletic like there's
nothing wrong with him
but i just don't like i don't like
softball chicks like no that [ __ ] ain't
i don't like it i don't like if you
there's a girl
at the gym listening to this with
headphones like what do you mean
i know she's like what is he talking
about
like if you rock climb get get out my
face too much yeah i don't like all that
really i don't like super athletic where
they just always want to be like they're
always like when you see them they're
like
hey jeremiah
they always got like workout gear on and
she's like that i'm like okay
they have ankle weights on someone i get
it [ __ ] you in shape okay
it's like i don't i you know what i mean
i don't that's not my thing you know
but it's just like i'm not a person that
works out all the time
duh right but you've lost weight though
i know but
i'm not as active as like i'm talking
about an active per like
she wants to like let's rent bikes and
go on like a 20 mi no
what we just got to the hotel i was
streaming on twitch in two minutes
yeah so like i that's not my
you know i just i don't like but at the
same time though like i remember when i
was doing
boxing there was girls at the gym they
went there boxing mm-hmm there was
something about that though that was
different
oh when you saw a girl yeah it sounded
like just you know going at those people
but still fine right right not the ones
that like they turned like you
you know from the back you're like oh
that dude oh [ __ ] yeah dude
yeah you're like oh that's a is that a
man
no my name is priscilla you know
priscilla was the name
of uh this sex shop that was in kansas
city for the longest time
and they kept i don't know if it was a
drug front or what because they kept
changing
the name to different gorillas so it was
priscilla's and then it would go to
sorrilas
and like i never understood like i
couldn't afford to change to all the
stuff
yeah we could do four we can do six
letters
you gotta keep those last three yeah i
saw
on your instagram that you went back to
kansas city
and you had a big write-up in the local
the local paper yes
so how are you i mean how was that for
you
dude so this paper this is what's
special it's the kansas city star
uh is the name of the publication and
this paper is very special to me and my
family because that is our weekly paper
so like that's like the paper in kansas
city that people get their news from and
stuff like that outside
you know that's not national like usa
today sure whatever
but like this is the local kansas city
thing like that i would get
every week as a special at the barbecue
place people exactly
all the all the coupons and stuff are in
there like i would read the sunday
funnies and stuff like that
is getting married yeah not like that
you can't say he makes sound like has 12
people in it oh
we never thought that was gonna happen
good for her you know what good for her
she's big so so all right so that it was
like
really important to you and your family
it was great because dude
so every sunday my dad and i would go uh
to different newsstands and i i had
something that i
i always would love to do i'd look at
all the ads in the paper like i couldn't
afford to buy the stuff but like i would
look at best buy and all the electronics
i've always loved gear and gadgets and
different stuff like that
so i would look at that stuff i'd read
the the cartoons in the paper and then
my dad would read the news articles and
stuff like that
and we just like eat breakfast on sunday
morning like before we went to church or
whatever but that's like
how we'd spend like 30 minutes to an
hour but like at the very beginning of
every sunday
and it's just like good memories
attached to that so that was the paper
and they just did uh a write-up on me
and
my one-hour special coming out on
tuesday december 8th on amazon prime
video on demand
and transition into talking about that
so tell me about that
you know because because no matter so i
know the first time i did a special
you know no matter where it's at or what
it's on there is something about like oh
wow i'm recording this
hour of comedy that is like that's the
thing you do as a comedian it's like one
of those like
it's like having a magic show at in
vegas sure
if you're a magician you know it's like
you're like i'm at the mirage you're
like oh my god i've
made it oh you know what i mean
so that's what it felt like so how did
it feel for you so
this was i didn't have that feeling
because
when i was filming these shows
originally i was going to put together
some kind of like crowd work special or
something like that i was going to put
out like a half an hour crowd work
um but basically i was doing stuff that
i was recording
uh for some other purposes that i was
gonna send out to siriusxm and different
stuff like that
and i went back there and filmed a
weekend of shows and how the special
came about
what made it what made me want to make a
special out of it is
the friday night show which is where
most of the special like
is like the material stuff came out of
uh
they sat my family in the front row ugh
i hate that
like so my dad and his wife
are on stage left with their friends
and then stage right my mom and her
husband
and her friends so i'm in literally in
the middle i'm surrounded by family my
brother and his wife are
in like in the middle of the crowd so i
like feel it
all around me so i walk out there i'm
genuinely shocked right
and then it's like okay how do i deal
with this
and i just rose to the occasion and i
made it and i freaking went for it and i
riffed on it and made it a part of the
show and the show is called family
reunion because it was an
unexpected family reunion that happened
yeah well that's a great kind of
um oh so but now that you have it all
together
i mean that's just how it is anyway
that's how it works yeah well that's
great man congratulations on that thanks
yeah once it was like
once it was edited i was like oh wow
this is like this is this is just this
is just cool it's an hour
of material that i've been working on
for years there's some great crowd work
moments and riffing moments that
that that's what i do anyway when i head
on the road in my hour
it's never like an hour of just like
material material material i like to be
just like
present work off the crowd just like
whatever environment and that was the
weird environment that night i was like
this will never happen again like my
family you know what i mean like that's
what makes it unique and like
yeah those are magic i know what you're
saying those are magic yeah i had that
when we were when i remember when we
were in ontario bro and then the the
the lady you know you're on stage
i'll never forget this because i hear a
ruckus because you're on stage
some lady comes up and cusses at
somebody
and then turns out they were you know he
was cheating on his wife
yeah with this girl he's with yeah and
then i come out and i'm just like okay
so
boom boom and it just turned into this
little piece of like you know
thing so i know what you're saying and
that you go when is it ever
to happen like daddy because it won't it
won't just like that so it's it that's
what to me like makes it a special and i
and i have
uh interviews with my family as the
through line so it's like it's just like
so it's just came together great yeah
that's awesome man i look forward to see
that i want to watch that because now
it's like
even knowing that it's not just your
comedy makes me want to see it even more
now
oh there's less screen time for you in
the hour oh is less of your material
[Laughter]
still a dick something's never changed
outside of kovit ladies and gentlemen
sing got him but i wanted to i wanted to
give you this oh
here we go he's giving me something
i need to drink some water somebody the
people complaining about the noises that
i make
i got bad sinuses and so this is for you
oh look at that everybody
my own copy of jeremiah watkins but i
wanted you
to look inside the album under the
special thanks
oh special thanks here we go special
thanks my wife
maija my family my dave roth tj mark
walter tj
i think i thanked tj2 in something he
was my first agent dude he's amazing
yeah he was my first agent yeah
gage tiruna johnny arena i don't know
any of these names i mean
your name is dude i know i want to see
if you know anybody that's american
[Laughter]
johnny svenzanzen
willie love dustin kaufman tony
hitchcliff brian redman and white tony's
ahead of me
uh the comedy store adam eagan bobby lee
jeffrey eric griffin there he is
wait okay at least i'm thank god i'm
ahead of dean delray
[Laughter]
in the thanks wow let me see let me see
the order here
bobby first jeff ross
those guys dude i'm not excusing you
stand up wise
everybody teasing you rita paige this is
a great list
ralphie may rest his soul yeah mitzi
rhetts her soul
brody uh brody too yeah miss brodie
can you i just i've been thinking a lot
about brody like during corn
stuff like that you want me why don't i
keep this one since you already have it
open
oh no you take this one okay yeah this
is a brand new one
since i'm packing are you know it's
hilarious i'm about to put it in my this
is my office knick-knack box that i'm
taking with me
do you wear flat brim hats do you wear
flat brand hats yeah i guess
uh-oh
am i getting more oh is this some this
is my merch jeremiah watkins hats
yeah i should have that actually i
should get embroidered on here
uh careless whispers yes like the
the you know what i mean but with your
name with jeremiah walking
you know my mom i know that's how she
always refers to it yeah he loves it
eric did jeremiah thanks man i
appreciate it yeah i do love these kind
of hat this is not
actually yeah no that it's dope yeah it
doesn't have your name on it so it's
perfect
that's what i like about merch though
like i don't like
comedians whatever you however you want
to do it i would rather somebody ask
like what it what does that mean rather
than just have my name plastered all
over it well that's nice because you've
been playing sacks for a long time we
talked about it last time you were on
here yeah
but you know where do you see yourself
going after this now i mean
you know it's like you we have to think
about how coconut has affected our lives
and our careers
so where do you see yourself now like
what what do you have a new perspective
on your career now because of everything
having a baby and covet and where
i mean i've learned that
i've been an ensemble player for so many
years out here
and it's gotten me to where i am right
now which i'm very grateful for all the
opportunities that i've had
leading up to this moment and because
i've been involved with
like a strange for a stand-up comedian a
strange amount of ensemble shows but
that's what i'm gravitated towards i
love working with people and that's
my sketch and improv background coming
out uh
but what i've learned is like that's got
me to where i am now
and i've gotta focus a little bit more
on
jeremiah specifically like what is the
show idea
that's going to get me the next thing
rather than
facilitating somebody else's show yeah
man i know what you're saying
i look back on it i wish i maybe i wish
i had thought about it more like that
in my early on time but i started comedy
so late
uh really you know attacking my career
like much probably older than you are
now you know
so yeah you you definitely should do it
you should do it like that and then
enjoy the process as you go along
i mean because that's the part that
sometimes we forget to do oh yeah
and then like when you take a step back
you realize like i need to be more
grateful this is amazing
yeah yeah like even like with dude even
with the pandemic that's going on
i've still been able to go out on the
road like a little bit and i'm super
grateful
because i mean there's a lot of people
that don't want to go out on the road
right now but i'm eager to
because i'm i'm still trying to you know
all the time become
a better and bigger headliner and all
that stuff so your shows are it's
actually a good time for someone
where what you're trying to do it's
actually a great time because these big
cats who are like you know they're
making all this money on weekends
they're like i'm not going for half the
money or whatever they're saying right
right and then
other people like i'll go i'll do it
you're like i have to do it i'm a yes
guy
you're trying to like yeah so i totally
get that there's there's a guy that you
you'd appreciate i've been doing
uh rather than um because i can't do
meet and greets anymore right now
because
of code going on uh on the road i've
been doing like these short q and a's
before i do like my last couple bits
right and um a guy in the audience he
goes uh
he raises his hand he goes uh what was
the thing that made you a celebrity
and i go i don't think it's happened yet
[Laughter]
that's very nice of you to say that i'm
a celebrity but i'm not
like that's that's you know what i mean
like i'm working on it
you know what was it you know it was a
turning point for me about how i felt
about you
it's something recent but recent when i
say recent
pre-covet bc okay
because if you think about it we're
almost going on a year now that we you
know been in this
yeah so i mean before that happened i
remember we were doing
a show for steve byrne
we were doing this really weird show for
steve byrne where
we're like they're we're we're the we're
the guinea pig comics on this like show
idea they have i don't even remember the
crazy show whatever the idea was but
like
you were you were you were just getting
roasted by
them and of course me you know which
i have to preface since we're bringing
this up they did not tell me
they did not tell me they told me this
is what they told me this is the only
reason i got
upset about it they told me i was gonna
do a late night set
right on their show and that was it
so i do the late night set
which is like a clean five in front of
hardly anybody that's in the audience
and i'm i feel like i'm like i'm i'm
there for the team you know what i mean
like i don't care that there's not
people there
yeah they start interjecting during my
set
i didn't know it was gonna be like that
they didn't they didn't tell me and then
they roast me
after my set and i'm like i did this
this is a sunday night i could be at
home right now like i'm in between doing
gigs on the road and stuff like
that but i remember seeing your face in
the parking lot
after and there was a certain feeling
that i could tell you had of like
it's like i deserve more respect than
this
or like a feeling of like like
not just i don't got to be grateful for
everything
that's really what i'm trying to say
yeah like like just because you have me
on your
like i don't have to say oh oh thank you
for
like you're like nah i'm doing you a
favor right like
i saw that in you you had an attitude of
like
i'm doing them a favor and they treating
me like this nah
and that's when i was like oh he's now
he's now flipped it
now you're ready to now because now when
it's time to get into this other stuff
because it gets work it's going to be
like that i know in hollywood situations
like real stuff
yep people are going to be like well we
want you to do this and you have to get
yourself to the point where you're like
nah
i'm not going to do that yeah like i
don't want to do that out of respect for
myself yeah yeah like i was going to do
this music video this guy i love the guy
i'm not going to say who it is but they
you know they
they they hit me up they just oh we want
you to be this character blah blah blah
and then they were like well
can you shave i was like no
you know what i mean yeah yeah it's like
and then the way they were like oh and
then they said well
we could move on to someone else bye you
know what i mean
later they weren't giving me
life-changing money
yeah yeah you don't understand it has to
be reciprocal at some point
so i just was like it's like you get
sometimes i felt like
that was a change in you of being like
no i'm in the business
i know what i have i have expectations i
have certain things i want to think well
it was a it's a small thing but it's an
attitude shift that i thought to myself
oh look at jeremiah he's going he's
going to get he going
he's going to make it well when you
start out as you know
it's very important to kind of keep your
head down and be grateful for everything
and sometimes in the process and by
sometimes
a lot of times you get pretty mistreated
along the way
and you have to take your licks and be
like well thank you anyway but like
after a point it's kind of like
when you do enough when you've been
doing it long enough like
and i'm not saying that i've been doing
it a really long time like 11 years but
that's still like
something yeah you know you're like i'm
out here
yeah that's kind of how i feel that's
kind of how i feel at this point it's
like i know i know
like people really start popping around
15 20
25 like all the like the amazing
stand-ups and stuff like that i get that
but still like don't disregard over 10
years of like
grinding like legit grinding yeah
again that chip on your shoulder is
really what i'm talking about
it's like you know you you you you
didn't let it stay on there
before it was trying to get on there and
you kept going stop
excuse me i was like lynn what is this
get out get out
you know it is cool all this stuff but
slam time sometimes
[Laughter]
sometimes that reminds you anybody who
has get treated better anybody who has
seen me uh
do let me phrase this properly uh
podcasting uh for a while knows that i
have a lot of patience
and that i can take a lot so if i'm
getting upset with something it takes a
lot for me to be like
hey man and that's a good by the way
that's a good quality by the way
but what i'm saying is what i can
appreciate if you having a balance
because it's a good quality to be
somebody that doesn't let things bother
you
i'm an emotional guy i'm reactionary but
it's a part of my comedy
which i appreciate you know but eric is
transparent about that though which i
appreciate because
like i was trying to facetime you and
you're like you hit me back immediately
you're like
i'm not in a good mood right now both of
us don't want to engage in this
conversation right now
thank you man i appreciate that you
telling me
like that you're in a not a good state
right now and you're not gonna hit me
back for like six hours you're gonna
like work through some stuff i
appreciate that so like it's it's
at least you let people know but it's
like but at the same time though like
the pardon me is like sometimes i feel
like i don't want to react but again
if doing comedy that way
it bleeds into my like regular life i
mean it's like that's just part of my
comedy you know people like
me being like you know that whatever
that character is
so so but there is something to being
like let me you know
be chill take it in you know and rachel
helps me with that
you should be like why are you upset
she'll say that like what are you upset
about right now and i go yeah why you
know i go you know what you're right
it's amaya doesn't mean she's like jesus
you know they're not thinking about you
right now exactly i go i know that
you know those kind of comments are like
those kind of comments are like a gut
punch that you need
you do need it you know what i mean like
why are you dwelling on when somebody
obviously doesn't care about you yeah
why am i worried about why are you
worried about that
i know like it's it's wasted effort and
wasted mental energy and then you had
this energy of like you don't you know i
had i had this
because this is what i probably have
when i have to deal with the trolls on
the internet and all that kind of stuff
and you know i react to things because
again
it's part of my it's part of my
comedic persona you know
i get riled up but i don't
i don't let it stay you know i'm just
like it's but with comedy you know you
have to
you repeat things so it's like you know
if i'm if i'm if i'm doing a set where
i'm like
aggravated about something i have to
express that
aggravation to give a great performance
you know
so that's part of the performance and so
that bleeds into your everyday life and
so
when you're streaming and you're being
an online presence and you're showing
some aggravation
then it turns into a thing where you're
like well i don't want this person to
know that you know but i don't think of
it like that i don't care
like i don't i'm not a person to say
well i'm not gonna let that person know
because then people hit you up and be
like
you're giving the trolls too much
attention and i'm like i don't
no i'm i don't it doesn't i don't care
right
but this i get like this because this is
part of my thing
it's just fun it's fun it's fun to see
you rolled up it really is that's what
i'm saying people
i've always been like that i knew i was
gonna be a comic when i was coaching
basketball
and i was on the sidelines and i'm
yelling at the kids
for whatever they're doing people behind
me
dying i'm i'm putting they're they're
just
loving it they're loving it oh coach
griffin he's going off
right now griffin's going out it's so
funny the kids hated it
oh i bet you of course you're right you
know here then
they're like right get back all day what
are you doing
yeah i'd be like are you point shaving
you know
who's cherry picking out there i would
be saying yeah i'd be like we're wearing
the red uniforms you know
until one time one of the kids said to
me i'm gonna forget this kid said coach
can you like not make jokes
cause like you know when you say certain
things
like we get embarrassed you know and i
was like oh
so you don't know you know what i mean
or you do know and you don't care
because you think there's another point
to it
and then or maybe i was caught up in
like you know i'm getting this oh they
like
but my problem was like i'm my thing is
i'm mad and they're laughing
so that would aggravate me right right
but yeah you're being serious
i'm being serious and they're like
that's just how i get mad
yeah you know it's in a funny way you
know what i mean so then they're like
they're [ __ ] laughing and that's the
first time i learned
i learned from that how to be funny
angry on stage
because i understand that oh this is
funny to people you know
real life but when it's like time to get
like
mad bad i'm not even like that at all
i'm gonna be well yeah it's a totally
different there's only a handful of
people who have seen
that that side of me exactly it's
because it's not
it never needs to come out really you
you the troll you ain't that important
yeah
when i get to that you're not gonna know
yeah you know so it's like it's just
we need that from like those loved ones
in our lives and so
you have a great way of like you know
you let things roll off your shoulder
and all that kind of stuff and that's
good
you know so we can all learn from from
from from that kind of thing i mean is
that
it's probably from your christian
upbringing or is this you got that from
one of your parents oh definitely i mean
that's that was something that was
instilled
very young the the golden rule you know
doing to others you'd have them do unto
you turn the other cheek that kind of
thing
yeah that still instilled me for years
and years
and i still try to to live by that it's
one of those things though where after a
while though
you realize that some people can take
advantage of your kindness and that's
when you're like
oh i got to draw the line here's my
boundaries yeah boundaries yeah
you could turn the other cheek but the
other cheeks coming with a left hook you
know what i mean
that's all it's like oh [ __ ] turn out
you coming with it jesus why
did you tell me to do this
yeah so that's good though man i mean
listen i i'm proud of you
you know i'm older i'm old enough older
enough
than you that i could say that to you in
the way that i'm saying it to you
is because i've seen you from when you
were like
a comedic baby no i appreciate dude you
like you i still like there's
there's some notes that you gave me
early on you air gave me some
some very very good notes when we were
on the road one time together of like
some things that
i should be working on with my material
that
helped you have certain conversations
along the way yeah i know what you mean
where
it's like oh i really need to start
working on
this aspect and that was something that
after we did some gigs together i was
like this is
great constructive criticism yeah that's
all it ever is
you know yeah you know but sometimes
again you know what you know what i
realized too is like not everybody
not everybody uh
needs that or wants that or so it's like
certainly certain relationships
even going back to our conversation
about who your friends are and certain
things like that
it's like i don't need to give those
gems to everybody
right right you have certain friends for
different things yes
you just do like in your network of
friends it's like yeah yeah yeah this is
the this is the
this is the friend i've been to this is
the friend that i exercise with like you
have your different i don't know
i find that i i find that i'm the friend
for people when they want
they call me when they want like um some
sort of honest truth about something
because you're yeah like if they have
like you're telling like it is friend
if they have a script they're like hey
can you look at this and you know you
want me to look at it
bro you want your dreams crushed that's
what i say
you should you you want what you what
answer you want we're doing scripting
with griffin
so i go sometimes i go should i not read
it and just give you some flowery words
because you need to hear that
or you want me to read it right like
what do you need from me right now tell
me what you need
but you know as but it's being a good
friend it's important actually it is
important to know that
you know cause i always say like being
honest don't excuse you from being an
[ __ ]
mm-hmm you know what i mean so you have
to like people have to know
you know because i'll never forget this
i remember siddiqui fuller
rest his soul too yeah man crazy that he
was dead right
he was you're just super talented
physically honestly
but i remember we were doing this
contest in seattle it was a seattle
comedy contest which is like
the worst i don't know if you've ever
done it but it's the worst
and they had to okay so what would
happen is there was a judge
like a celebrity judge usually just an
ex-winner or some local comic who like
you know and so the crowd
after your set if they applauded extra
you would get a bonus point and the mc
is the one that decided that
you know and so
sadiki was fighting with the mc they
they were having a thing
and so after siddiqui said
the whole thing happened he didn't get
the point from the guy and he comes to
me
and he's looking and he says he's like
eric i know you'll tell the truth
it's the one time i lied did you know
why
he needed to he needed he needed that
reaffirmation
yeah he needed it i i saw in a moment
and i knew in a moment i was like damn
i am putting myself in a situation now
is this how people are going to come at
me
like do i have to be this guy like it's
not always fun
like you don't want to always be the
person while you say something to
somebody and they look at you like
thanks eric you know oh [ __ ] you know at
that moment i thought
but it was 50 50 at the time so did he
you think he should have got the point
or no i
i think it was it could have went either
way oh like it wasn't enough of it
it wasn't enough right but at the same
time man you killed
right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he
he you could have got it you know what i
mean
i didn't go all the way but it was like
it's one of those things so you you get
yourself
you're broken out of here no you're not
killing this like i'm
just crushing them on the side of the
stage thanks a lot eric they were
already fighting i just felt like so
sometimes you
add to it yes and i think about that i i
often think about that as like
what kind of dad do you want to be
oh man i want to be
i want to be a fun dad but i also want
to
like my dad was very good about this i
felt like
he was very fun and good at like
when it was playtime or whatever you
know he was great
at like being like present with us but
like
when the law was going to be laid down
like we really respected and
listened to my dad and i would like to
be somewhere in that like i don't want
to be scary
or anything like that but i want to be
like listen like
you need to to be this kind of person
yeah
you know what i mean but i guess you
have a partnership with you know it's
like
good cop bad cop you know it's like you
know you get cuddled from this person
and
the other person comes with that
discipline i mean i guess it's like oh
man
when you really start to think about i
guess these are things you have to start
thinking about huh
i haven't thought too much yeah about it
like how are we like you know are you
going to be a disciplinarian are you
going to be you know what i mean are you
going to be like you know i think i'll
end up being
the disciplinarian out of uh the two of
us
oh you're so sad about it i think i'll
have to i think i'll have to
i know but i don't know my wife like
she's literally been
for years in child care and that's like
what she has her degree and stuff like
that so she knows like
so much about the whole process that's
gonna get annoying
that's gonna be it's gonna be annoying
when she goes jeremiah in my experience
you should you're gonna be like hey hey
hey come here
i know how to raise the key yeah yeah
yeah because i was raised
and i used to be a kid i know it's gonna
be
that's gonna be like you're gonna you
guys are gonna i think you'll find your
way you found your way
she's like so such a sweet person that
she is like
i think i wanted you to get her pregnant
i know you've been telling me for a
while she was gonna do it if you didn't
like she's fertile man she's ready to go
she told me she's like tell eric i said
hi she loves you
yeah you guys are great i was really i
actually really was happy to hear that
news
and i'm happy to hear all this news
about you and i love having
conversations with you we've already
been on so long so let's let's jump off
of this right now and then
you know have you on again because i
don't have a lot of guests anymore so i
guess i do have i want them to be people
that i know
um but even though even after i say that
watch in two weeks it'll be like
i've never met you before thank you for
coming over from griffin hey man that's
my podcast that's how podcasting is so
you never know but
please uh let's hear about the special
again is going to be on what and where
and when yeah amazon tuesday december
8th amazon
prime video on demand apple tv roku
like there's a lot of outlets so you can
purchase it and rent it uh
rather if you want to see it um and then
the album if you're more of an audio
person comes out
on december 10th on on all platforms
and uh you can get it through
jeremiahwatkins.com or just go to amazon
prime
and hit that rental button yeah jeremiah
stand up on social media i
post a lot of clips and stuff like that
so yeah i'm a fun follow yeah he is a
fun followers pocket and then check out
our video
we have our video from a distance yeah
from a distance we did he
you know what he put it all together
it's funny he hit me up he was like
hey you know actually i was hitting him
up about doing some music stuff
and then you had an idea and then you
just you know
from how you were talking about it i was
like well this actually should be your
thing and i'll just
be in there with you right you know
because you had a whole lot you had a
whole
you know and he put it all together
music video and then now it's out there
and it's just like a check mark of like
oh we did this fun thing thing together
like it lives yeah it's great it's it's
a it's a piece that i'm still really
proud of and it's weird that like
it still is like very it's gonna be
relevant for a while it's like
you know i know about like keeping
distance from hoes and stuff like that
like it's going to be real you should
actually do a re-release right now
because we have the the
you know the order it out again this
week
why not put that sucker out again maybe
i'll put it on my youtube now because i
didn't put it on mine before
do it yeah did you send it to me send it
to me i'll dropbox you
you know i'll put it on my youtube i'll
make some reels for us yeah 30-second
thing
oh so many things to keep up with i know
i can't keep up with it but
but reels is just like hot girls that
can't dance
they do they do things like this hi hi
hey boom
uh uh uh-huh yeah there you go
okay sure great tips
yes
and then you just go what are you doing
you're like all right like
i mean double tap okay okay i mean i
guess
i know i don't even i can't do that
anymore by the by the way rachel just
hates when i like any
so my like right now yeah this is me now
yeah ooh that's nice
[Laughter]
you're tapping on outside of your phone
yeah okay double check yeah
like oh that looks good i just i just
like like this girl
yeah because yeah but anyways thank you
jeremiah for coming on
and and check out air experiences on
jeremiah wonders they're so fun
oh that's right yeah i didn't even see
the one with uh when i
popped in on steve steve lee's that
comes out this week actually oh well
there you go
check that out yeah that's out right now
it's out right now so check out that one
uh i'm on jeremiah's i popped in on the
steve lee episode you guys know
steve it's yeah to have eric and steve
and me all in one room it was eric calls
it a nightmare vegas
tonight it's so fun the only thing that
would make that worse is a rick glassman
there let's start a super podcast that
would be oh my god
you rigged jeremiah it's just we're done
and maybe add adam ray
oh dude would be insane the amount of
laughing and dumb riffing though
dumb stuff going on that'd be great but
uh this has been jeremiah watkins this
is eric griffin
and thank you for watching we're from a
griffin make sure you share subscribe
and i'm on twitch every day eric griffin
gaming
and thank you guys for being here and i
will see you next week
you